[Music]
some people run for fun finding solace
in the heat of the Sun some people run
to lose weight
shedding pounds with every stride they
take some people run to get but not me
I run to refrain from a being that you
cannot see one that's whatever it's
something I cannot foresee and nothing
that groups up so quietly black clouds
and gods my personality
experiment rules crass pushing on hoping
to slide past its towering heights and
empty stash beckoning me to stop but I
don't dare heart studying pain ensues
but I'm flying in my running shoes heart
studying pain and Sue's the one race I
can't afford to lose heart sudden pain
ensues pain ensues pain ensues
exhaustion creeping through my mind as
it shivers up and down my spine darkness
so cleanly confined and as my pace slows
I realize I've ran out of time it's hot
I'm claustrophobic it creeps into my
stomach where it bubbles and bites it's
aching my insides skin morphing from the
heat stifled screams ooh gritted teeth
the side I hide is tearing through
gripping me so tight but I can't let it
reach you you're too precious to consume
so I stay confined to this room away
from Beauty until the space until I can
breathe
until I know it's safe until I learn how
to fight and I'm granted back my sights
because when I can't see the only escape
is to flee
thanks to better help the supporting
this video and helping me share with you
how I deal with my struggles but his
life's not always easy but when you feel
like you can't deal with this alone then
it might be time to bravely step out of
the darkness and seek help better helps
an online counseling service that's made
it easier for over six hundred thousand
people to have a listening ear that's
something we all deserve if you feel
like you're struggling then please check
the link in the description to see if
they can help you or like me perhaps go
for a run